Good morning.
Well today is what I hope is an
exciting day at Khan Academy.
We're going to start a new set
of, I guess we could call
them, lectures.
But what we're going to do is
I'm actually going to work
through just a bunch of SAT
problems. So what this is
going to be is like SAT prep for
free, or Princeton Review
or Kaplan for free, and I hope
neither of them sue me for
using their names.
But anyway, what I want you to
do is, if you haven't already,
I want you to buy this
book right here.
The Official SAT Study Guide.
Let me make sure it all fits
into the-- you'll see it in
the bookstore.
I hope I'm not doing any kind
of copyright infringement.
I'm not a lawyer.
I don't know all the rules.
But I'm pretty sure as long as
I give them credit and that
you know that all the problems
we're going to be doing are
from their book and I'm just
going to work through them,
hopefully that shouldn't be
something that's wrong.
Every day-- well not every
day, but as often as
possible-- I'm going to work
through all of the problems in
each of the math sections.
So the best thing for you to do
is for the same section, do
them ahead of time for yourself,
try to do as many as
you can, score your test, and
then whichever problems you
don't know, you can just watch
on Khan Academy and hopefully
understand them or re-understand
them.
So with that said, let's
get started.
So I'm using this
book right here.
Official SAT Study Guide, and
I am starting on page 395.
This is section three,
I believe, of
the first math section.
This is page 395.
So sometimes I'll
write the whole
problem, sometimes I won't.
I'm going to assume that
you have the textbook.
So with that said let's begin.
So the first problem, problem
number one, it says, if 2x
plus 3 is equal to 9, then
what is 4x minus 3.
Well this is just a very
basic algebra problem.
If you don't remember how to
do this you should probably
review the level one and level
two linear equations lectures
that I have in the
algebra playlist.
But the way we do this, we could
solve for x here, so we
can just subtract 3
from both sides.
2x plus 3 minus 3, so you get
a 0 here is equal to 6.
And x is equal to 3.
So if you do 4x minus 3, that's
4 times 3 minus 3.
Right, that's 12 minus 3.
And that also equals 9.
And there are some, you could
have kind of done this a
little bit faster.
But this is the one way that you
would make sure that you
got the right answer.
And on this test it's B, 9.
Number two.
There are 8 sections of seats
in an auditorium.
So I will write-- let me do it
in another color just keep
things interesting--
8 sections.
There are 8 sections of seats
in an auditorium.
Each section contains
150 seats, but no
more than 250 seats.
So if we say S is seats.
Let me say S is seats.
Seats are greater than or equal
to 150 and less than or
equal to 200.
This is seats per section.
I hope I'm not confusing you.
Which of the following could be
the number of seats in this
auditorium.
So before I even look at the
choices, I mean you could put
in the choices, you just have to
figure out, well what's the
minimum number of seats
in this auditorium?
Well the minimum number
is if every section
only has 150 seats.
So the minimum number is 8 times
150, 8 sections each of
them having 150 seats.
Because this is the case in
which every section has the
smallest number of seats.
So 150 times 8-- 0, 40.
1 times 8 is 8 plus 4 is 12.
So this is the minimum number
of seats in the auditorium.
And then the maximum number
would be if we assume every
section had the maximum
number of seats.
So that would be 200 times 8.
That's easy.
2 times 8 is 1,600.
So we know that seats is going
to be greater than or equal to
this and less than
or equal to this.
And what choice falls
under that range?
Choice A doesn't, it's 800.
Choice B doesn't, choice
C doesn't.
Choice D, 1,300, does fit in
that range, and we know that
choice E doesn't fit
in that range.
So we're done.
It's D, 1,300 seats
is a possibility.
And we turn the page and
we a graphical problem.
Let's see what we could
do with this.
Note: Figure not drawn to scale
in the figure above.
Let me draw this.
I think I'll have to explain
how it's done.
I will use sky blue.
So the figures-- let
me draw that line.
No, let me do it better
than that.
Draw a thicker line than
that so you can see it.
So they have a line like that.
And they have another
line that goes up
and down like that.
And then they had a bunch
of points, so let
me draw those points.
I will draw them in
a different color.
So we have point A, point B,
point C, point D, point E.
And they call this horizontal
line, they're
calling this line L.
And then no, they have another
point up here.
Point X.
In the figure above XC is
perpendicular to L.
So this XC is perpendicular
to line L.
So we know that this is
a 90 degree angle.
And I think they draw it.
Yes, they draw that.
Which of the following
line segments has
the greatest length?
Oh, and in the figure they also
tell you the measurements
of the different lengths.
So they say from A to B is 3.
From B to C is 2.
C to D is 3.
D to E is 1.
And from C to X is 8.
Which of the following line
segments that are not shown
has the greatest length?
So the first choice--
I'll write the
choices down actually.
Choice A is line segment XA.
Choice B is line segment XB.
Well this is following
a pattern.
Choice C is line segment XC.
Choice D is line segment XD,
and then choice E is line
segment XE.
So which of the following
segments has
the greatest length?
So just eye-balling it, you'll
know that XB is definitely
going to be shorter.
XB is definitely going to
be shorter than XA.
Why is that?
Because if you used--
well one, you could
just eye-ball it.
I know it's not drawn
to scale.
But you definitely know that
this length, this base, is
longer than this base
right here.
So we know it's not
going to be XB.
We know XB is shorter
than definitely XA.
So we can cross that
one out, right?
Now what we don't know-- and we
could do the same thing on
the other side of this
perpendicular line.
We know that XD is shorter
than XE, right?
Same reason, because we know
this base is longer.
If you use a Pythagorean
theorem, you would know that
this hypotenuse is going to
be longer than this one.
And you can review Pythagorean
theorem and get familiar with
the triangles if that doesn't
make a lot of sense.
But that tells us that it's
definitely not going to be XD.
And we also know it's
not going to be XC.
This is the shortest
of all of them.
And you could eye-ball that.
So it's either going
to be XE or XA.
And the way we figure out
which one has the longer
hypotenuse is we say, well they
all have the same height,
so which one has the
longer base?
So this one has a base, this
triangle right here-- if we
say this triangle-- has a base
of 4, and this triangle here
has a base of 5.
So this hypotenuse will be the
longest. XA is the answer.
I will see you in
the next video.